liyan Mitch are they in the house yeah
[ __ ] that was an uncertain one yeah it
sounded like preeclampsia or something
that sounded painful Ali right started
lifting listening to eight I'm sorry
Mitch right starting to listen to HBO
around Thanksgiving and have been a
loyal fans since I'm sitting in the club
with a lady named Ali on April the 8th
the reason I'm writing is because I have
not been able to talk her into receiving
the money shot yet have you met David
and Jenny can I get into specifics what
would the money shot specifically be
does that mean shoulda never touched
your wiener she's that the facial the
facial you're talking about that's what
so never okay so she's never had the
facials never had the [ __ ] why are
you asking Ralph about this I guess
we're ready to walk her into it really
perhaps you and Kevin could help me out
Mitch says either by talking her into it
or receiving the money shot yourselves
is it any port in a storm for you Mitch
I just want to come on somebody's face
tired of the athletic sock
want to watch somebody flinch anybody
man woman animal I just need to spackle
somebody seriously I want to make
[ __ ] Hawaiian Islands on somebody's
mug oh yeah I want to make face pancakes
what's more slang for come I'm not gonna
give it all the way I gotta save some
for later
go save some come for later Kevin yeah
Adam wait a sec let's go back to the
problem why do you want to do that man
cuz he really really loved the ladies
the ways in her hand man look I'm with
you tell him to come in his own [ __ ]
face oh come on Kevin you're not helping
it's ridiculous man it's just like one
thing this beautiful woman's you give me
so much love and then she keeps me at
night I don't feel alone and I don't
want the one I ever kill myself but she
won't let me come in her stupid face
listen you can't the heart wants what
the heart wants
okay turn-ons and you can't you can't
you know you can explain them away it
just it is what it is and Mitch
obviously wants to come on her face I
think you got to add sevens like you can
come my face as long as I could stick a
bowling pin up your ass at the same time
that's the move like that's our deal I'm
ready if you are
go obviously that Ali is so special that
her face is so special she can't have
come on it you're welcome it
you loosen up you and I were the only
two in the room daddy give it to me
daddy that always you and him are meant
for each other
because apparently both want to come in
somebody's face just hook up man here's
the thing porn has warped up super years
I think if you watch a lot of porn you
start getting ideas and saying yeah that
looks [ __ ] fun that doesn't even feel
good like when I come I want it to be
somewhere wet and [ __ ] warm like
rather than come on someone's face I'd
stick it in a pump or something [ __ ]
the Troublesome one yeah you wanna [ __ ]
some fruit and you know it is a fruit
because it has seeds that's right you're
welcome Mitch and I wish you the best
tonight with Ali's face we're not taking
the money shot for you though I have to
break the news to you my advice to you
ma'am is to be like okay I'll take it
and [ __ ] and then when he's about to the
moment of truth happens immediately go
all wide mouth frog just so you catch it
all and then be like
right back in his face with his own [ __ ]
Tripps office knows and [ __ ] and you're
like you still want to put it in my face
that's what my mother did to my father
and it worked
I'll never forget seeing that
Thanksgiving was never seen again at
your house was it you're an angry angry
lover Kevin
[Music]
you
[Music]